Filmmaking is a painstaking process, one that
usually takes months, sometimes years, to
complete.
Your average film takes two to four months
to shoot, with bigger-budgeted films often
taking much longer, as each and every scene
usually requires multiple takes.
A talented cast and crew can make all the
difference, and it’s always helpful when
your stars manage to nail a scene on their
very first try.
Here are Screen Rant’s 10 Incredible Movie
Scenes Nailed on the First Take.
Rocky
A relative unknown before his breakout role
in the boxing drama, star Sylvester Stallone
fought tooth and nail for his script to be
adapted exactly the way he envisioned.
After convincing producers to allow him to
play the lead role, Stallone and the rest
of the crew had to cut plenty of costs, but
the actor refused to let this crucial scene
be one of them.
With the film running behind schedule, Stallone
was allowed only one shot at Rocky’s most
vulnerable moment, confessing his insecurities
to his girlfriend, Adrian.
Thankfully, that was all he needed, and the
character’s pivotal moment was kept.
10 Thing I Hate About You
This romantic comedy launched the careers
of its trio of young stars: Heath Ledger,
Joseph Gordon-Levitt, and Julia Stiles, with
the latter’s high school poem giving the
movie its title.
The poem could have been a little corny, but
was given an added layer when the then-17
year old Stiles slowly broke down into tears
on the very first take, an acting cue that
was not in the film’s script.
First-time director Gil Junger was so moved,
he called a wrap to the shoot after that,
and the scene’s only take continues to live
on in ‘90s pop culture lore to this day.
The Man with the Golden Gun
Thanks to the innovations of CGI, spectacular
action pieces are far easier (and less dangerous)
to pull off than they used to be.
Roger Moore’s second outing as James Bond
featured one of the most outrageous stunts
in movie history, one that reportedly had
several ambulances watching from the sidelines,
fearing the worst.
When the angle, speed, and rotation were all
calculated and built to let gravity deliver
a perfect barrel roll, stunt driver Loren
“Bumps” Williard not only managed to avert
disaster and pull off a full corkscrew, he
did so on his very first attempt.
And earned a huge bonus for it.
The Master
Both Joaquin Phoenix and Philip Seymour Hoffman
received Academy Award nominations for their
work in Paul Thomas Anderson’s The Master,
and with scenes like this, it’s easy to
see why.
Phoenix’s unhinged performance as an alcohol-addled
follower of Hoffman’s character was on full
display in this largely improvised scene.
Phoenix goes absolutely berserk, and his first
take at the scene was the one Anderson chose
to use in the final cut, for obvious reasons.
Phone Booth
Already well on his way to Hollywood’s A-List
in 2003, Colin Farrell teamed with director
Joel Schumacher to star in this psychological
thriller about a man held hostage in a New
York City phone booth by a sniper.
The shooter, played by Kiefer Sutherland,
demands that Farrell’s character come clean
to his wife about his marital infidelities,
resulting in an emotional scene that the actor
managed to nail down on the first take.
The entire film was shot in just 12 days and
proved to be a sleeper hit with critics and
audiences alike, thanks in no small part to
Farrell’s stellar performance.
Beauty and the Beast
The climactic theme song of this Disney classic
underwent several changes on its way to winning
Best Original Song at the 1992 Oscars.
Originally conceived as a more up-tempo rock
song, it was eventually retooled into a romantic
ballad to better fit the scene.
Angela Lansbury, who portrayed Mrs. Potts,
was initially reluctant to provide the vocals,
thinking herself a poor fit for the style
of song.
At the directors’ request, the actress recorded
one take as a backup, in case no other options
were found.
Lansbury reportedly brought the entire studio
to tears with her performance, and audiences
followed suit when the film was released a
year later.
Lord of the Rings: The Two Towers
Working with animals is never an easy process,
no matter how well-trained they are, but it’s
probably much easier when you’re dealing
with the Lord of all horses.
Shadowfax was said to be capable of running
faster than the wind and understanding human
speech in the Lord of the Rings novels, which
would help explained how he was able to nail
down his majestic entrance on the first take.
Complete with a dramatic twist of his head.
It turns out the horse was more than ready
for his moment in the spotlight.
Citizen Kane
Continuing the trend of cinematic classics
is screen legend Orson Welles’ film debut,
widely considered one of the greatest and
most influential of all time.
That also means its home to one of the most
critically acclaimed one-take scenes, when
the main character’s wife leaves him, sending
the decaying mogul into a violent tirade,
completely destroying her bedroom.
Given the destruction Welles caused to the
set, the first take of this infamous scene
was, understandably, the only take.
That was all the actor needed, and one of
the film’s most iconic moments was born.
To Kill a Mockingbird
It’s probably the most memorable one-and-done
scene in movie history.
Gregory Peck’s performance as Atticus Finch
earned him the title America’s greatest
movie hero of the 20th century, and the unforgettable
closing statement in which Finch demanded
the jury “do their duty” was originally
planned to take several days.
But the seasoned veteran of the stage and
screen somehow managed to nail the speech
in only one take –
that alone was enough to guarantee Peck’s
first and only Best Actor Oscar.
Alien Resurrection
Finally, can a shot nailed on the last take
be just as impressive as the first?
Allow us to explain.
One of the few bright spots of the fourth
entry in the Alien film series was Sigourney
Weaver’s infamous no-look basketball shot
in the movie’s first act.
After spending weeks practicing, Weaver was
only hitting about a sixth of her attempts.
The director preferred to just add the shot
in later – which is why the shot was staged
with the ball leaving the frame – but allowed
Weaver six attempts to pull it off for real.
With 5 misses, the actress put her last chance
to good use.
The cheers from her co-stars meant the shot
had to be cut immediately, but Weaver delivered,
hitting nothing but net.
The rest of the movie?
Not so much.
So what did you think of our list?
Did we miss any of your personal one-take
favorites?
Let us know in the comments section, and be
sure to subscribe to our channel for more
videos like this one.